what what muscle group or muscle groups
do people complain about the most saying
odds it's so hard to grow this
particular muscle group certainly calves
all right I would say the same thing so
isn't it interesting that maybe we have
one weird trick for massive calf growth
uh not really but
um yeah I'm talking about a study that
was published recently from warnicky and
colleagues the title is influence of
long-lasting static stretching on
maximal strength muscle thickness and
flexibility and for this segment I'm
only going to be talking about the the
muscle thickness bit
um you know I I think most people
realize that stretching a muscle
improves flexibility over time not
really worth getting into but the the
hypertrophy findings were were pretty
interesting
um and we we posted about this study on
the stronger by science Instagram a
couple weeks ago uh check out the
Instagram if you haven't already
and uh the the post got a lot of
Engagement and also a lot of questions
um suggesting that I think some people
didn't fully understand why we were why
we were talking about this study in the
first place
um so I I wanted to do this segment for
the podcast both just to talk through
the study and the results of the study
more but also I think it's a very useful
study for helping us learn learn more
about the process of accruing scientific
knowledge over time because studies
don't just exist in a vacuum you know
and I think most most consumers of
information are interested in science
for the purpose of giving answers of how
should I train to maximize gains but
generally there's a fairly long process
getting you to that point of trying to
figure out not just works best like not
just what works best but why it works
better than other Alternatives like
understanding mechanisms which can then
be used to guide future research to
actually optimize training
um so reading between the lines where
people basically saying like this is
this has low ecological validity like
it's not directly applicable well they
were basically saying like oh well
resistance training has to be more
effective than stretching for calf
growth so like why should I care in the
first place okay yeah uh so yeah let's
um let's kind of Trace trace the history
that brings us to this study
um to discuss why it's important so uh
just as a background
we've known for a long time that
training through a full range of motion
uh tends to cause more muscle growth
than training through a partial range of
motion uh the classic study that people
tend to cite to to support this point is
by Bloomquist and colleagues uh but
there there have been plenty more
studies that that have been published in
the intervening years uh the the
Bloomquist study was from either 2011 or
2013 I believe and in that study they
compared the effects of basically
quarter squats so squatting to about 60
degrees of knee flexion versus uh
parallel squats so squatting to about
120 degrees of knee flexion uh so you
you can see if you're watching this on
YouTube what those ranges of motion
looked like in in the graphic that we're
gonna put on screen
uh so cool image too it looks like the
person's wearing like one of those
Spider-Man suits it is yeah it looks
like a skeleton in a mo cap suit so
high-tech and spooky cool
um so you know subjects trained through
these two different ranges of motion uh
for 12 weeks following the same training
program and basically they found that
the the group doing parallel squats
experienced way more quad growth than
the group doing shallow squats uh and
also if you're watching on YouTube we'll
we'll flash these results up here but
you know for for the most part they
measured
um they measured quadriceps
cross-sectional areas so so just
cross-sectional area of all of the
muscle mass on the front of the thigh at
uh six different points so some some
more proximal points closer to the hip
down to more distal points closer to the
knee and what you saw was at basically
all points uh the the Deep squat group
uh experienced increases in muscle
cross-sectional area of like four to
seven percent in that pretty tight range
the shallow squat group did see some
pretty decent hypertrophy at just the
more proximal regions uh so closer to
the hip
um but then for for the distal regions
they saw no changes in Quad size or even
slight decreases so overall the the Deep
squat group just saw way better quad
gains than the shallow squat group
however
uh with with a type of study like that
it's difficult to isolate variables
because you could say oh hey uh you know
maybe the difference we're seeing here
is due to the fact that the total range
of motion uh was different so the Deep
squat group was training through twice
as much total knee flexion as the
shallow squat group or you could say
it's because the mo the the muscle links
being trained were different so Not only
was the range total range of motion
different but the Deep squat group as
they were going down they were training
the quads at longer muscle lengths
longer total muscle links than the
shallow squat group so is it the muscle
links that matter or is it the total
range of motion it's hard to say just
from the Bloomquist study and from uh
probably the first half dozen studies
though we're looking at this question
so uh more recently there have been a
few studies that help disambiguate this
a little bit further so
um I I'm going to talk about a study
from Pedrosa and colleagues that will be
linked in the show notes but there there
have been uh some some studies
illustrating a similar Point by Sato and
colleagues and uh mayo and colleagues
maeo I believe
um but yeah the the study by pedroso was
the first that I think really helps uh
disambiguate that effect is it the
muscle links being trained or is it the
total range of motion so
in in the study by Pedrosa uh there were
five groups uh one of the groups and all
of them were training knee extensions
over 12 weeks uh one of the groups
trained through a full range of motion
which they defined as from 100 degrees
of knee flexion to 30 degrees of knee
flexion so they basically had a custom
built knee extension machine rigged up
where subjects didn't lock out all the
way at the top I think to kind of
maintain muscle tension in all of the
groups not totally sure but basically
100 to 30 degrees of knee flexion was
full range of motion in this group then
they had an initial range of motion
Group which only trained from 100 to 65
degrees of knee flexion so only training
at relatively long muscle links so not
doing the top part of the range of
motion then they had a final range of
motion Group which only trained from 65
to 30 degrees of knee flexion so same
total range of motion as the initial
range of motion group 35 degrees of
total
knee flexion range of motion
um but they were only training at Short
muscle links then there was a varied
range of motion group where essentially
they would do half of their training
with partials at long muscle links and
half of their training with partials at
Short muscle links and a control group
and there there were a lot of outcomes
in this study so there were five groups
they looked at two different muscles
both the vastus lateralis and rectus
femoris and they also assessed uh muscle
cross-sectional area at four different
points along the thighs so you know
there there are what like somewhere
around 120 discrete uh comparisons you
could make in this study but overall the
the trend was pretty clear
um all of the groups that trained at
long muscle lengths so the initial range
of motion group the varied range of
motion group and the full range of
motion group uh all experienced more
quad growth than the final range of
motion group that was only training as
short muscle links and they all did
better than the control group which is
what you should expect
um but this strongly suggests that the
important factor with full range of
motion outperforming partial range of
motion isn't the range of motion per se
it's the fact that when compared to kind
of the traditional approach of partial
range of motion training full range of
motion training involves training at
long muscle links and that seems to be
the important part because when you do
partial range of motion training and
long muscle links that seems to be just
as effective for hypertrophy as full
range of motion training or if anything
may be slightly more so like uh that and
that's somewhat and big ambiguous but at
minimum it seems like partial range of
motion training at long muscle links is
at least as effective as full range of
motion training which suggests
range of motion per se doesn't matter
all that much but there's something
important about training at long muscle
links for promoting hypertrophy so then
the next question is basically why like
why is that so much more effective
um and now we're getting closer to where
the calf stretching study comes in so a
hypothesis that's been put forth to
potentially explain why training at long
muscle links is particularly effective
for hypertrophy is the concept of
stretch mediated hypertrophy which is
essentially the idea that a
active contractile stimulus when also
paired with a stretch stimulus leads to
more hypertrophy you know better
intramuscular signaling that would lead
Downstream to hypertrophy uh than just
that active contractile stimulus
um so that that's basically the idea of
stretch-mediated hypertrophy
and we've we've I think reached a point
in some segments of the fitness industry
where that's already accepted as fact
like uh part partial range of motion at
long muscle links is really effective
for hypertrophy and full range of motion
training is really effective for
hypertrophy because of stretch mediated
hypertrophy and we know that's the
mechanism driving it the thing is we're
not there yet uh that is still a
hypothesis that hasn't been fully proven
and the the evidentiary basis for it
like there's certainly a theoretical
argument you can make for it
um you know if you wanted to make an
argument about total tension on the
muscle
presupposing that all hypertrophy just
comes down to Mechanical tension and you
look at maybe increases in passive
tension as muscle links increase and you
say oh well the stretch media mediated
hypertrophy that's because at long
muscle links you can put more total
tension on the muscle bigger hypertrophy
stimulus that is certainly a logical
train of thought but if you are
interested in approaching this from an
empirical perspective
like every discrete step in that train
of of logic it hasn't been fully proven
and elucidated yet so currently stretch
media mediated hypertrophy is just a
hypothesis
and it was a hypothesis on
somewhat tenuous ground from my
perspective and the reason for that is
most of the time not all of the time but
most of the time when you have a
stimulus you know is effective for a
particular outcome so in this case you
know resistance training active muscular
contractile tension we know that's
effective for hypertrophy if you do
something else to augment that to make
it even more effective generally the
thing you're you're augmenting it with
is also at least to some extent
effective for hypertrophy in its own
right so a good analogy here would be
protein intake so you can't just force
feed protein and get huge without
resistance training but we also know
that independent of resistance training
protein intake does do a lot of nice
things related to muscle protein balance
so you know without a resistance
training stimulus if you eat more
protein you might lose muscle a little
bit slower without a training stimulus
uh and you know I'm comparing like kind
of normal to soup super low protein
intakes there we know that that
mechanistically
consuming enough leucine in a meal will
trigger muscle protein synthesis like
there there are a lot of those little
variables like that where you can look
at protein and isolation and be like oh
this should do some nice things for
muscle itself so then when you pair
adequate protein intake with a
resistance training stimulus that
protein augments the resistance training
response to give you better results than
you would see otherwise and so that
that's what you tend to see for things
that that might augment training
responses and the thing with stretching
is there wasn't great evidence that it
did independently do much for
hypertrophy outcomes at least in humans
and with
uh any sort of reasonable stimulus so
there there were some chronic stretch
studies in birds and cats and rodents
back in the 80s and 90s which basically
found like if you put Birds wings under
a weighted stretch for weeks at a time
it caused ridiculous amounts of
hypertrophy and muscle hyperplasia
um but you know like when we're not
birds and two that hand had been
independently observed in humans and so
if you if you want evidence like
indirect evidence for the concept of
stretch mediated hypertrophy it sure
would be nice to have human evidence
showing that stretching itself uh posed
a hypertrophy stimulus to the muscle
um and there had been
some prior suggestions that stretching
per se could result in hypertrophy so
the study there that people would most
commonly cite was by Simpson and
colleagues uh published I think in like
2015 2016 where uh subjects had one leg
that they stretched for six weeks one
leg that they didn't stretch for six
weeks and the stretch was a loaded calf
stretch on a leg press machine that they
would hold for three minutes five days
per week so three minutes per day five
days per week for six weeks loaded calf
stretching and that study did report
that uh that that stretching
intervention led to hypertrophy but uh
we'll uh again if you're if you're
watching this on YouTube will will Flash
the results up on the screen comparing
the stretched and non-stretched legs and
really it's not a slam dunk case so the
difference in uh in calf thickness in
the stretched and unstretched legs was a
little bit less than one centimeter at
Baseline and was ever so slightly more
than one centimeter after the six week
intervention
um which the the authors reported was a
statistically significant result P of
0.04 barely significant it was the type
of thing where uh depending on your
perspective you could look at the study
and be like okay this is some amount of
confirmation that stretching is an
independent hypertrophy stimulus but if
you wanted to be more skeptical you
could look at it and be like okay like I
I want to see more like this this isn't
super convincing stuff quick
interjection here
um
to prove that I'm paying attention you
you set a difference of one centimeter
should that be a millimeter oh yeah yeah
0.1 centimeter yeah okay yeah my bad
um
so yeah it was
um
essentially there was
a a little bit of Prior evidence that a
stretching intervention might lead to
hypertrophy in humans but it was
I I I personally wanted to see more
right
um so the the study I'm talking about
here from warnicki uh was what I would
term a
um
a a proof of concept study so
essentially with a proof of concept
study what you're trying to do is you
think that an effect exists and you try
to stack the deck in your favor to
greatly increase the odds of you
actually observing that effect so a
great example of kind of a whole area of
research where there are a lot of proof
of concept studies is studies that are
interested in looking at different
recovery modalities and the way those
studies tend to work is they put people
through a muscle damage protocol that
far exceeds anything anyone would ever
do in practice so you know it might
involve 75 maximal eccentric Reps for a
particular muscle Group which
if you've never done that before that's
I think almost an Eighth Amendment
violation like it's it's rough you're
gonna be [ __ ] up from that
um but you know it's causing so much
soreness so much muscle damage that if
whatever recovery modality you're
interested in if it will improve
recovery that is the type of situation
where there's so much to recover from
that you will be able to observe that
effect if you just kind of put people
through a more quote unquote normal
resistance training stimulus where
people would just recover in 48 hours
just fine anyways you know even if the
thing you're studying was very effective
you might not be able to observe that
effect because you hand it adequately
stack the deck in your favor so I I
would call the the warnicky study a
proof of concept study for the potential
impact of stretching on hypertrophy so
the the training intervention was more
intense and longer lasting than I think
most people would do on their own so it
was also a six-week intervention like
the Simpson study it involved daily
stretching lasting for one hour a day
much like The Simpsons study subjects
had one leg that was stretched one leg
that was unstretched so each each
subject served as their own control and
essentially there was a calf stretching
orthosis an orthotic device that you
would put your foot in and there were
basically straps that you could pull to
pull your toes up pull your ankle into
dorsiflexion
that's right right yeah yeah I always
forget dorsiflexion plane reflection so
yeah you could pull your toes up to pull
your ankle into dorsiflexion and
essentially lock it in for an hour
um and subjects were instructed on a one
to ten Pain Scale to stretch to the
point of an eight and I doubt they
actually got there
um because like if if 10 is the most
severe pain a human could be in and
eight is probably like a broken bone
um and I don't think they were actually
stretching to that intensity it was
probably more like a six I would guess
but anyway uh put yourself in a pretty
uncomfortable calf stretch and hold it
for a full hour and do that every day
for six weeks uh which like I said in a
proof of concept study that's that's
more stretching than I think most people
do for a particular muscle group
um but you know this is the type of
study where if stretching can cause an
independent hypertrophy response this is
the type of study where we would see it
and if we do see hypertrophy in a study
like that that confirms that a stretch
stimulus might be an independent
hypertrophy stimulus which would help
make more sense for why stretch meeting
stretch mediated hypertrophy might be a
thing like it helps put that concept on
firmer theoretical and and evidentiary
footing uh and essentially that's what
they found uh so over those six weeks of
stretching the stretch legs experienced
an increase in uh calf muscle thickness
of about 15 so that's a that's a pretty
notable increase compared to just two
percent in the control legs and also
there was a good uh a good population
used for this study so they weren't
completely untrained subjects they were
quote athletically active having
performed two or more training sessions
per week in a gym or a team sport
continuously for the previous six months
so you know once again it's not like the
the type of thing where with completely
untrained folks uh you know anything
might be a hypertrophy stimulus like
we're seeing uh calf growth just from
stretching in folks who are at least
like recreationally trained
um
so overall I I think this is is pretty
promising uh like I said the main
takeaway of this study I think is that
it puts the idea of stretch me mediated
hypertrophy on firmer theoretical and
conceptual footing uh and like I said
kind of in tracing the progress of
Science in this area over time we
started with the observation that full
range of motion training led to more
growth than partial range of motion
training the next question is why is
that is it total range of motion or is
it the range of motion being trained
then more recently we had studies saying
hey it's probably the range of motion
being trained uh the the fact that
you're training through long muscle
links that seems to be more important
than total range of motion per se and
then the next question is well why is
training at long muscle links
particularly effective might it be this
idea of stretch mediated mediated
hypertrophy well if it is it sure would
be nice to see that stretching per se
was an independent hypertrophy stimulus
which would help it make sense for why
it might augment regular resistance
training induced hypertrophy so
essentially that's where we're at now
and then the next question is what can
we do with that uh you know can we use
this information to make kind of normal
resistance training interventions more
effective uh you know and it could be
that we're a few years away from a
breakthrough where we find out hey maybe
full range of motion training is you
know certainly effective but maybe
partial range of motion training at long
muscle links is even more effective so
you know maybe maybe the Bros were right
the idea of constant tension training
not locking out your reps that they may
have been on to something like that may
lead to more growth than just kind of
standard full range of motion training
uh we have yet to see and fully confirm
that but you know that's sort of the
next steps to take after a study like
this
and one thing I will note
is even though I would term this uh a
proof of concept study the the type of
thing where most people probably want to
do themselves you could actually do this
so if you're really struggling with calf
growth and maybe you're insecure about
your small calves uh or you know if you
just want to
um you know maybe maybe do Omar esoph a
solid send this to him
um this is the type of thing where you
you could actually implement this
intervention so they were just
stretching one calf you could do this
with both just get some orthoses uh and
if you're sitting for an hour a day at
work uh playing video games watching TV
you could just put your foot in that
orthosis get it in a stretch and just
chill out for an hour
um
I don't know how many people will want
to do that but that this is
theoretically a practical intervention
someone could try to boost their calf
growth but but for the most part it is
mainly a proof of concept study
um
so yeah like that's
that's mostly what I wanted to talk
about the the point that I wanted to
make clear
um is that by talking about this study
on the podcast posting about it on
Instagram
um I'm certainly not saying that
stretching is more effective than
Lifting for muscle growth and I'm not
saying that you should try like just
stop training your calves and only
stretch them to promote muscle growth
that's certainly not what they're saying
this is more about trying to figure out
why something works and in this case
trying to figure out precisely why full
range of motion training tends to be
more effective than short muscle length
partials why partials at long muscle
links seem to be particularly effective
for muscle growth whether the whole
concept of stretch me mediated
hypertrophy holds water in the first
place you know it very well could be
that training at longer muscle links
does lead to more hypertrophy due to
some mechanism other than the stretch
stimulus like that's certainly still on
the table so this study uh helps helps
confirm that the stretch stimulus very
well could be augmenting the normal kind
of resistance training hypertrophy
response
um and also I'll note that
this is also the type of study that
could potentially be useful for clinical
populations so one of the issues if
someone say comes down with a really bad
disease gets hurt really bad and they're
on bed rest for a few weeks one of the
issues you run into with recovery there
is if if you're on bed rest and you
can't move around at all people just
Hemorrhage muscle and strength to the
tune of losing strength at a at a clip
of about one percent per day and muscle
size at about half a percent per day so
you know if you're on bed rest for a
month uh you you're in rough shape when
you come back and so just for getting
getting back up and reconditioning
yourself just for day-to-day life like
that that uh can cause issues like just
the muscle and strength loss and so if
if it could be that just intensely
stretching a muscle for an hour a day it
if that's effective not even as a
hypertrophy stimulus but just for
maintenance of muscle mass in those
sorts of situations
um you know it could be a an efficacious
intervention that that people could do
in situations where they can't
resistance train
um so it's also useful from that
perspective but yeah for for the most
part I I wanted to talk about this to
mainly just trace the the story of
scientific discovery because most people
really do just want to be told okay well
that's cool and all but like how do I
train to get [ __ ] huge and strong and
jacked But ultimately This Is The Stuff
leading to that stuff
um there's almost always this process of
progressive Discovery you make an
observation you try to explain that
observation and then the next answer
leads to another set of questions
um and you know it is that that
incremental uh process and since uh
since range of motion and the concept of
stretch me mediated hyper BR I think
kind of hot in the fitness industry
right now I think it's work I thought it
was worth kind of taking a step back and
tracing how we got here and
how you might go about answering
questions to more fully elucidate why
these things seem to work yeah this
brought up a lot of flashbacks for me
um
the worst feedback the most criticism
I've ever gotten for an Instagram post
was also a kind of proof of concept
study and uh I swore that day if I ever
post again about a proof of concept
study I'm going to have a disclaimer at
the beginning middle and end of the post
uh because I think I caught a lot of it
yeah it was like a caffeine post and
people were like Eric you are the
stupidest person I've ever met who would
take nine milligrams per kilogram of
caffeine and it's like well if you want
to see how caffeine works that's one way
to do it yeah you know and it's the same
kind of thing with this like the utility
extends far beyond the experimental
design just from the uh the proof of
concept but yeah if you want to see
hey can stretching a calf grow it like
yeah throw them in the boot for an hour
and see what happens yeah you know so
it's it it's very helpful to see why
things like this are useful even if
you're not saying hey go home and
replicate this uh this experimental
protocol in its entirety absolutely